I'm David Thorburn I'm a professor of
literature and comparative Media but
what about what else I taught the film
experience for I guess 38 or 39 years at
MIT and I taught a lot of literature
subjects as well the store the story of
what made me into a film scholar or a
media scholar is at least interesting to
me and so it still surprises me I've
told it a few times but it was actually
a somewhat transforming experience in my
life I have been teaching at Yale for
seven or eight years and I was offered a
chance to do a visitation at the
University of California in Santa
Barbara and for the first time in my
life I was asked to teach students who
weren't the product of very elaborate
public of a private school education zor
very powerful public school education
they were smart kids but they were less
well read in some ways so I was trying
to illustrate it was a literature course
introduction to literature or comedy
something like that and I was trying to
introduce the students to the idea of
conventions what it means what it means
when a store when you begin a story once
upon a time and every story begins that
way or what it means when you say they
lived happily ever after to take the
simplest example of what a convention is
I was trying to illustrate how in fact
we internalize these things and we
understand the conventions of the
narratives of our own time in our blood
without even thinking about it and I was
trying to illustrate this principle so I
was what I needed to illustrate the
principle were shared texts so I began
by asking them this was in the 1970s in
the early 1970s and I asked the students
there these are bright california public
school students how many of you have
ever seen a John Wayne movie maybe ten
percent of the students in 1970 it's not
2016 now it's too you know maybe fifteen
percent of the students raised their
hand then I said well how many of you
have read Huckleberry Finn maybe thirty
percent I tried other novels
classic novels i tried Shakespeare plays
finally I said how many of you have seen
all in the family for those in the
audience too young to know this all in
the family was a television program a
classic and transforming one that
appeared in 1971 on American television
and involved a working class hero who
had never such characters had never
appeared on television before was a very
important program and of course a
hundred percent of the class had seen it
and I began to take my examples from
television programs i talked about the
conventions of situation comedy as a way
of explaining and this and i began to
think about this and i began this war on
maybe I worried on me as the term went
on and and I what I realized was that
the literature of our own day the story
forms that belong to my students and to
the generation of kids I was teaching
were visual not literary or at least
many of them were and the ones that were
shared a hundred percent which were
shared by everyone was certainly
televisual so I became interested in
television as a narrative medium and
that of and then I came to realize as I
began to think more seriously about the
role of television in American like
remember by nineteen seventy American
television was deeply embedded in
American life it was the dominant form
of entertainment and narrative in
American life and in fact this initial
understanding which are out of which my
whole interest in media developed has
shaped I realized now just in talking
about this my view my way of teaching
the tell the course the film experience
and it's one of the things I think that
makes the film experience unique because
I began thinking about television I was
not a film scholar I was not a media
scholar I was a literary scholar in fact
ironically I was a specialist in the
high modern period a period of Joyce in
Virginia Woolf and Picasso right and I I
you know I knew about what we might
think of as I was an expert in art that
could be thought in forms of art that
could be thought to be a leader store at
least not accessible to the to the
ordinary people and here I was
confronting text that everyone could
understand and everyone shared we get to
think about them more deeply and
more deeply about my own literary
education which was narrow in some sense
as everyone in my generation was so
educated we we were cut off from the
historical implications of the texts we
studied so I began to fill that in as
well as I began to learn more about
television and what I realized thinking
about television was I couldn't
understand television without the movies
so I then set on a sort of personal
course of education and I read very
deeply in movie history and movies
scholarship and I you know amplified my
own knowledge of movies tremendously by
constant viewing of movies mostly
because I was trying to understand
television ironically and then I began
to develop a recognition of what a
remarkable cultural phenomena in the
movies where I began to generate great
respect for the great movie scholars who
it was a great era the set the late 60s
and early 70s for movie scholarship
because it had become mature by that
time and the people writing movie
criticism in the United States certainly
in the 1970s were very interesting
critics critics and scholars the
equivalent of the literary scholarship
that I was used to that I aspired to
write myself and so forth so it was very
exciting intellectually for me to have
this experience when I got back to Yale
after my years visitation I introduced a
course called literature and popular
culture in which I explore these ideas
in greater depth and in with greater
intensity I read some bestsellers I
ended I ended the course by looking at
the honeymooners and I remember I was
teaching the course in in a room at Yale
College called linsley chittenden Hall
in which the great Shakespeare cool
letcha course had been taught for
generations and my course literature and
popular culture was very popular with
the students I had a couple of hundred
students and I was lecturing from the
same podium that legendary figures had
Lake lectured on Shakespeare about and
one of these legendary professors the
man who had actually hired me at Yale
Maynard Mac a great a great literary
scholar poked his head in while I was
teaching the honeymooners and I had
actually Dragoon the
people that at Yale to give me a
reel-to-reel tape recorder so I could
tape the stuff off the air max saw this
and and later called me into his office
and expressed great disappointment over
the fact that I was polluting this this
environment so then I when we then had a
serious conversation and I said to him
what did you what did he actually think
Shakespeare's environment was and that
was when it struck me how narrow my
education had been because he really had
not even though he was a great man and
agreed he knew the history but he
somehow had managed to disconnect the
literary power of Shakespeare from the
fact that it was done on this incredibly
popular stage and it was so sensational
and it was so much more like a
television or the movies then it was
like some process of sitting in a in a
library in wood-paneled splendor reading
words in silence that's not what
Shakespeare was and that began to lead
me into recognitions of the importance
of popular culture the fact that most
high culture was a form of popular
culture I became much less apologetic
than most teachers of copy of the
culture are and so when I came to MIT in
the in the mid-70 came to MIT and night
in in 1976 and I was already in the
throes of this but it was I think
fortunate for me unfortunate for MIT in
one sense because mi T's literature
program was much more open than Yale's
had been and they were interested in my
work on television and media that was
one reason they wanted me to come here
and it was much less hidebound about
literary and historical study here so it
gave me a chance to sort of and I
introduced a course in television then
that was one of the very first courses
in the American Academy that studied
television programs for their content
now that's common it's thought to be of
course everybody takes it for granted
but at that time it was very rare thing
and what I also did was take a course
that I inherited from my wonderful
colleague still teaching here in his
eighties Alvin cable a course called the
film experience which was a course that
was not intended for all students
a small one i transformed it into a
general introduction to film and I've
taught it almost every year since